[Aplausos]
[Música]
en tu experiencia en estos procesos que
tú has tenido pero también dándole
énfasis a la improvisación
estigmatizar acerca de la improvisación
al momento de tratar de resolver algún
problema o durante el proceso creativo
como es mi caso
conforme pasan los años
que no hay una sola forma de resolver
algún problema sino que cada quien como
somos distintas personas pues puede
haber distintos caminos también para
llevar a cabo esto con su atractivo o
resolver cualquier tipo de problema de
la vida cotidiana
totalmente creo que
sea el rubro de adjunto abajo pero
mayormente en los artistas en las
personas creativas el proceso creativo
tú crees que tiene fases que deban
cumplirse al pie de la letra o cada
quien en su experiencia en su vida en su
manera de ser en sus pensamientos igual
si es nocturno un poco más mañanero por
todas esas cosas influyen en este
proceso yo creo que la clave está en
cómo nos preparamos como explotamos
nuestras herramientas
y me refiero a que las oportunidad no
siempre llegan o cuando llegan llegan a
una sola vez y si no estás preparados
y creo que es demasiado importante el
explotar tus talentos o sus aptitudes en
cualquier tipo de carrera o en cualquier
tipo de disciplina
creo que ahí está la clave
cuando se habla de improvisación pues se
tiende a pensar que es algo
irresponsable pero yo creo que va más
allá y creo que así como el tiempo
nominal pues tampoco la manera de
resolver estos problemas cada quien
tenemos nuestros propios procesos y
tiene mucho que ver conforme te preparas
conforme recibes el problema si de hecho
algo que comentabas creo que la
improvisación
si lo que se tiene que ejercer en ese
proceso creativo porque bueno tal vez se
van a hacer esta fase voy a iniciar con
eso después con esto pero algunos
problemas pueden ser técnicos puede ser
del ambiente puede ser del mismo tiempo
en las personas que te rodean igualmente
en tu caso a lo mejor que nos gustaría
que nos practicarás de alguno de un
proceso creativo que has tenido que te
ha marcado y que la improvisación ha
tenido que salir a flote precisamente
puede ser por presión puede ser por
presión social por a lo mejor es la
manera de nervios cualquier situación
humana que pueda
yo creo que el proyecto más conocido es
el mural de juan gabriel y te platico de
manera rápida cómo fue cómo afectó en mi
persona y en mi trabajo
en 2015 en marcha en 2015 me llaman para
realizar un mural en la unidad pared en
un edificio de 10 pisos de altura casi
500 metros de cuadrados
era algo más
espontáneo era algo más improvisado
precisamente pero no estaba planeado que
por gabriel se enterara yo la gran casa
de juan gabriel un día antes yo con un
concierto en el paso texas aquí una
frontera y decidí ir a ver como yo
empiezo a pintar el mural yo no me
enteraba todavía sino que me habló una
reportera cuando yo fui el primer día me
tuve que ir porque no llegó la grúa y me
dice oye que fue con gabriela a visitar
la pared y me río digo no lo que dice
físico y te está buscando a partir de
ahí cuelga empiezan a llamar de medios
internacionales y medios locales se
empezó a apuntar la gente ahí en la en
el edificio alrededor y fue una presión
tan grande que
me empecé a perder control total de lo
que estaba haciendo de entrada para
gabriel da una fecha para el venir a
inaugurar el mural y fueron diez días
después de que yo comienza entonces
llamé después el tiempo muy limitado
que yo tenía ya la prensa encima yo
tenía ya las personas el público y
encima también y siento que si yo no
hubiera estado
preparado conforme han pasado los años
no lo hubiera hecho o sea yo aún así veo
el mural y a veces pienso que
sí mujer ha puesto más a pensarlo no me
voy a subir a la verdad porque también
pasaron accidentes pasaron todo tipo de
cosas que caí este por poquito no se
hace pero siento que llega un punto en
que cuando controlas tu talento
logras brincar soportar los cálculos y
utilizarlos a tu favor y eso es muy
importante todo tomarlo a tu favor de la
manera más sabia posible y por ejemplo
ir a platicaba de esta situación que
tuviste en este mural que es reconocido
internacionalmente
en este proceso que tuviste en este
proceso creativo cómo es que tú dices
voy a hacer un mural de juan gabriel con
estas tonalidades de este tamaño con
esta frase como llegas a decir esto es
lo que voy a hacer
cuando a mí me plantean el edificio a mí
se me vino a la mente juan gabriel
porque era la avenida donde el pasado su
infancia adolescencia y donde
prácticamente nació juan gabriel
posterior a que él se entera y
según el proyecto pues con una razón no
iba a ser el me empezó a pasar algunas
fotografías originalmente
era yo tenía la idea de ser un retrato
en un poquito diferente al que hice al
que pinte pero él empezó a pasar
fotografías y quería otro tipo de imagen
donde él estaba con cuerpo completo y
yale plantillo que yo te ayudaba que
fuera él y le plantee que quería hacer
un retrato de manera que se viera del
otro lado de la frontera y le agradó
mucho la idea y le agradó la idea a
partir de eso él dice bueno quiero ir
enamorarlo por tal fecha ya no me echo
más tiempo como desee ahorita
[Música]
pues ya se fueron dando solas también o
sea ya circunstancialmente se fueron
uniendo pues ya medios es la misma
cliente me baja o yo y opinaba o me
preguntaba si así va a quedar o me
aconsejaba que le cambiara ciertas cosas
porque pues no les gustaba si les
gustaba entonces el pintar en la calle
siempre es un reto porque
pues a diferencia de cuando se hace en
el estudio estás tú frente al cuadro
tienes vista total del formato y
controlas no pero cuando estás frente un
edificio de 500 metros cuadrados eres un
puntito dentro de esta gran pared y es
como si caminas en un mapa de deslizarse
en un mapa y tienes que agarrarte de las
imperfecciones del muro para poder
realizar la imagen no también es pintar
mural de este foro de este gran formato
es como tu vista cambia cuando pintas un
cuadro
de cierta forma ver líneas ves puntos y
acabes por las manchas gigantes este
aprendes a de configurar la imagen y a
llevarla a cabo ha traducido al muro
pero está
claro y en esta ocasión por ejemplo las
opiniones estas voces externas que a
veces bueno debemos confiar en nuestra
voz interna en en esta es mi creatividad
este es mi proceso este es mi ejemplo mi
experiencia pero como acceso para que
estas voces externas no afecten tu arte
y también tu proceso llegó un punto de
que dejas de ser consciente y el
subconsciente
toma poder pero pero es de lo que decía
no es improvisar tal cual sino es como
confiar plenamente en tus aptitudes que
has ido entrenando conforme pasan los
años y llevar a cabo desde ese momento
por ejemplo por ponerte un ejemplo yo
tenía miedo a las alturas
y estado ya pintando a 50 metros de
altura y si en un siempre que me subo
una grúa ahora tengo un proyecto muy
duro y siempre que me subes miedo pero
estás ahí y estás frente a la pared y
dejas de existir y sólo existe la el
trazo que están haciendo las manchas que
estás haciendo no piensas a pesar de que
tengas a 300 personas viendo que estás
pintando un mural y te dan la opinión y
el pri de que te están hablando medios y
que te bajas y te quieren entrevistar y
dar la entrevista pero mi mente se queda
ahí por ponerte un ejemplo ahora mismo
tengo 10 proyectos 10 murales en tres
proyectos diferentes a la vez y conforme
estoy practicando contigo mi mente
también está pensando en lo que estoy
haciendo ya y en lo que voy a hacer
llegando mañana o más tarde y es así
continuamente
por ejemplo en este tema como haces para
que llegue la creatividad porque muchas
veces uno la mente se queda en blanco no
sé cómo hacer esta situación no tengo
inspiración tú arturo cómo te inspiras
cómo llega esa creatividad
bueno yo creo la inspiración pero como
decía picasso la la inspiración existe
pero te tiene que encontrar trabajando
yo no pero en la inspiración como algo
mágico que viene y se apodera de mí
pinto simplemente lo más difícil en
cualquier aspecto en la vida es empezar
una vez que empiezas una vez que yo
empiezo y hago el primer trazo en una
pared lo demás viene solo o sea ya una
cosa te lleva a la otra y aunque vengan
errores los suns a tu favor dentro de un
trazo mal hecho por ejemplo lo utilizo a
mi favor y creo que aplique también en
la vida
sí totalmente es muy cierto lo que se
aplica en en cualquier circunstancia en
la vida da el primer paso que es el más
difícil el primer paso como tú
comentabas la primer línea el primer
punto la primera el primer golpe a la
escultura sea lo que sea en cualquier
parte artística pero por ejemplo ahorita
platicaba de los errores crees que el
error sea como una barrera para ya no
continuar o el error lo puedes utilizar
simplemente como es parte de mi arte yo
lo utilizo a favor o sea siempre va a
haber errores en cada pintura en cada
en cada cuadro en cada mural pero
siempre lo
borro por ejemplo sino que me sirvo de
ello o tal vez este error me lleva a
otro camino que yo no tenía planeado y
es por eso que cuando empiezo un cuadro
no sé cómo va a terminar porque también
si supiera ya no lo haría no ya se le
quitan como las ganas ya lo resolvía
aquí qué caso tiene llevarlo a cabo pero
el cambio esta experiencia de estos
errores que te van llevando a otras
cosas y que termina escribiendo un
resultado que no esperabas que funciona
y que comunica algo a las personas pues
eso lo sientes
increíble esa parte creo que es la misma
pasión que es la que te permite
sorprenderte y no solamente tomarlo como
un trabajo sino también tu parte de
diversión tú continúas con esta pasión
sí claro de hecho ahora que tengo estoy
lleno de trabajo estoy agotado pero no
lo tome en cuenta hasta me sale energía
de donde ni siquiera sé porque también
hay meses donde no llega nada de trabajo
no llegan murales todas las demás por
ejemplo no dice nada mural y ahora se me
juntaron todos como si estuvieran listos
esperando pero contento o sea llegó a la
casa cansado y apenas se no a veces
índice un eje dormido y me levanto a las
6 de la mañana a seguirle al día al otro
día y contento o sea es algo
inexplicable como esta pasión que yo he
tenido desde el niño me lleva a hacer
cosas que no imaginados
si totalmente y bueno también como parte
final me gustaría que tu arte vernos
platicar a esas personas creativas a
esas personas que ha tenido miedo de
iniciar con ese proceso creativo que que
les dirías en este momento ya en tu a tu
experiencia
bueno en cualquier disciplina yo
recomiendo mucho el escuchar a ti mismo
a uno realmente saben lo que quiere en
la vida aunque a veces pareciera que no
yo creo que es enfocarte yo siempre he
sido de la idea de enfocarte en una sola
cosa y explotarla menos es más y si en
mí en lo personal se trató de abarcar
muchas cosas descuido algunas
desde niño desde que yo recuerdo me
aferraba a pesar de que tenía obstáculos
grandes sobre todo en un principio
batallaba muchísimo para vender las
pinturas que me contratan para algún
mural sigue siendo complicado a veces
pero no todo el región y creo que la
persistencia está la clave en hoy y lo
que te decía hace rato el primer paso es
lo más importante ya de ahí que nadie te
pare y es una bola de nieve que va a
llegar aa
a explotar no se va a llegar a tener un
resultado que puede impactar a tu
sociedad y activismo emocional si es
alguna vez o más bien no sucede que no
se financia por último cuál es esa parte
artística o ese mural que te ha llenado
de tanta emoción y de amor y que te ha
impactado
bueno por dejo yo te diría que le ponga
abriel por el hecho de cómo la gente se
ha adueñado de este mural se ha
apropiado de él sobre todo por juan
gabriel caliente se les tiene no
le tengo un cariño especial este mural
con un homenaje yo tuve la oportunidad
de hacerle en vida al señor juan gabriel
hoy es su aniversario luctuoso el 28 de
agosto
pero el cica mural nuevo es un reto y es
esta sensación como si se me olvidará
pintar siempre al llegar a un mural y el
primer paso es precisamente por eso es
que es tan difícil no pero ya que ya en
este proceso te vas a enamorar de cada
mural y de cada obra pero también he
aprendido a desprenderme de ella sobre
todas las pinturas porque porque cuando
pintó un mural deja de ser mío se queda
para en la calle para la gente que pase
lo ejecutaran transcurso en su casa o
una pintura y pintó este nuevo el joven
y como ya no volverá a ver y que están
en una colección particular o en alguna
galería o en alguna casa de alguien y
cuesta desprenderse de algo que sale de
ti
pero ha sido lo más sano también si no
ya me hubiera vuelto loca
claro que sí bueno pues muchísimas
gracias a damasco por estar el día de
hoy aquí con nosotros un gran aplauso
por favor para arturo damasco que esta
tarde
[Aplausos]